he gets seen by a fishing boat finally
after 76 days
and he's so dialed in and like accepting
of his situation that when the guys come
to save him he goes no no you guys go
ahead and finish fishing and then pick
me up when you're done so he literally
sat there and waited for these guys to
finish their day of fishing
just waited in this raft he's like hey
76 days what's another six to eight
hours
what do most people have wrong about
toughness what is it not
uh well what i think the the
biggest common uh mistake people make is
that it's
we see it as being a masculine quality
or somehow inherently related to manhood
or or
the the condition of being a man
and i spent a lot of time in that early
on in the book really breaking it down
and explaining what exactly
being tough truly is and it has nothing
to do with sex gender
or any of these things they are totally
independent
elements uh that anybody can attain with
the proper
you know work and understanding um
and the the kind of the secondary part
of that is that it is associated a lot
of times with
kind of violence or aggression or
that that sort of need to
demonstrate our ability or our
superiority over others
and again totally unrelated to what
being tough
truly is uh but we we have these
associations in our minds
especially based on our past experiences
with people who claim to be tough or who
mothers tell us are tough which is often
far far off the mark there's been a
recent i would say in the last five
years i've noticed quite strongly a
surge
in content around fortitude and
resilience and toughness and
people like david goggins are being
really upheld and
cold showers are becoming a thing and
you know
why do you think people are drawn
toward a discussion about toughness in
2021
i think because you simultaneously have
it
becoming less of a normal trait
for people than it used to be but
more and more necessary for us to get
through our lives now
and those things are related certainly
uh you you look back at say like my
grandfather's generation
uh going through the great depression
world war ii
uh these sorts of things where you know
my grandparents grew up
on farms they were dirt poor
there were traits that you developed as
a child growing up in a situation like
that that you know a lot of people still
do in
you know both of our countries of course
but where it wasn't this thing that you
sought out it was just something that
naturally you developed because there
was no other choice
you want to eat or you better figure out
how to eat and it's going to take some
work
versus my daughter's generation like hey
i want to eat they boop boop
and someone delivers food to their door
20 minutes later while they're sitting
there watching
you know 15 000 different shows on tv
uh so it's it's this totally different
experience that we're having in our
lives
and i think what's happening is that
more and more of us are recognizing that
there is something missing that we're
there's an absence of experience um
and uh you know a sense of fulfillment
and contentment and accomplishment
because we're not required to engage in
things that are difficult and demanding
and require commitment
uh in in an understanding of who we
truly are and what's important to us so
we're kind of just
flailing around uh searching for ways to
entertain ourselves and distract
ourselves which temporarily is
satisfying but in the long term kind of
leaves us having
a you know a continual series of midlife
crises
right so instead of having one midlife
crisis like the
olden days now we have one every five
years it's like what have we been doing
what do i want to do who
am i this is awful and so i think that's
why it's becoming more and more
of a popular topic how do you define
toughness then what what is it if that's
what it's not
what is it
so i break it down into four uh elements
the first one is character
and that is simply what is your identity
and and the corollary to that is are you
secure in that identity so who are you
and what is important to you what's
meaningful to you
because without that that's your guide
for every decision you make
and so many of us are just absolutely
clueless
when it comes to who we actually are a
lot of us have stories in our minds that
we've been telling ourselves about who
we are for our entire lives
uh most of the time very far from
accurate uh but that's kind of what
props up our egos and makes us believe
that we have this kind of dialed in and
figured out
and the security and identity is key too
because so many of us are
totally insecure in who we are and
that's why we have so many of us
uh you know constantly on the search for
recognition
and appreciation and and credit and uh
you know the these desperate pleas for
validation
you know look at social media every day
it's just it's sad
honestly um and so much of it is
unconscious like
people are not setting out every day
like i need someone to tell me i'm
i'm strong and pretty uh but that's what
it is
and and and without that security we end
up with the you know
those kind of uh behaviors and also you
know the ridiculous unnecessary
competition and the one-upmanship and
all these
things that just drive ridiculous
behavior and prevent us from
accomplishing anything
actually meaningful long-term
next you have capability which is
not just physical ability and physical
traits and skills
but knowledge it's in its your we need
to garner this through
the accumulation of very broad
uh experiences novel experiences and
learning
you know collecting more and more tools
physically mentally
emotionally in learning how to succeed
through different situations
unpredictable situations
and gaining the confidence that comes
along with
successfully experiencing such things
next we have capacity which is what you
know most people think of as resilience
but
i distinguish this from resilience in
that you know resilience technically is
a return to your original condition
following some kind of adversity or
trauma right so that to me the analogy
is
storm comes you go downstairs you ride
it out in the cellar you wait for it to
clear up you go back and just resume
your life
that's resilience that's good right
we're not getting destroyed by it but
what i want is
to use those experiences that adversity
hardship challenge to
to develop further to become stronger
more intelligent more engaged with the
world
uh to you to add to that toolbox to get
more experience using those tools in
in unique novel ways and then finally is
commitment and this encompasses uh you
know discipline
uh habit building routine these sorts of
things
and this is really what brings all of
the previous three together because
without the commitment to it
the rest is just kind of a private
fantasy right you this is the story
we're telling ourselves well i
i am resilient and i am capable but if
we don't actually put those things
into use during meaningful significant
uh experiences then we're not those
things
we either have the potential to be those
things or we're just lying to ourselves
uh and so that that's what kind of wraps
it all up and that's how we create that
life
going back to character do you think
it's built or revealed
is character something that's innate or
is it something that we have to
construct uh i
don't think it's innate although i do
think obviously we have
uh much of it is built without our
participation early on in life right
it's
you know through our influences our
parents our family our friends
our teachers coaches whatever um and so
you know when you're six years old
you're not
conscious of the development of your
character unless you're some kind of
you know genius prodigy kid but
uh so because of that there's always
opportunities for character to be
revealed for us to experience something
that forces us to look at who we are
at present but at the same time i do
think we have
you know a complete ability to determine
who we are to decide our character
uh to figure out what then you know the
behavior the speech the ways of thinking
then support that identity and then to
make those changes in our lives to
reflect it so it's it's a you know a
dialectical process where maybe we
experience something we see
wow this is who i am it is not who i
believed i was this is not who i want to
be
so who do i want to be and now more
importantly
how do i actually make that true what do
i need to change in my life how do i
need to behave and think and speak
in order to actually become that person
rather than just thinking this is who i
would like to be
man the more that i look at learning
about character
and personal values and why are you here
looking at the core reasons for you
being on the planet
i don't think that there's a more
important question that anyone should be
asking themselves
it took me until i was 31 to
do sit down and actually work out the
five core values that
my life is built upon which is mental
how did i get through
18 years of full-time education two
degrees including a masters
and no one ever said why are you here
like what what's the reason that you're
here i've done it for businesses
so the young entrepreneurs that are
listening who've sat down and said right
okay so let's talk about the brand
values that we've got
while the people sat around the table
haven't got their own values organized
yeah it's bizarre and and
what's more bizarre is that as you said
they can be
completely uh
unaware of the ridiculousness of that
situation
where they're putting so much effort
into what what is meaningful to my
business right like the business is this
living entity that has its own values
it's like no
those are your values expressed through
your company
so like why why would you not do this
for yourself
it's bananas yeah it's um
it really is i think it's one of the big
changing points a big inflection point
that you have
when you actually sit down and do that
exercise and i've been banging on about
this for
for the last year so everyone that's
listening will be familiar with this but
for the people that
haven't already decided to do this
exercise i implore you whether it's
through
greg's book tough which will be linked
in the show notes below or
taylor pearson's uh core values exercise
which you can get online or whatever it
is
like you need to do it what was life
like for you
before and after was there something
that where you realized right i need to
sit down and get my core values in order
or
have you always had them set no
no i definitely have not uh had myself
sorted out always
uh it's been it's been a
a continual series of of events that
have
kind of nudged me in in various
directions and
um it is something certainly that is
ongoing right so even if you do sit down
you figure out your values today
um those things are very likely going to
evolve over time based on
new experiences new interactions with
different people and new demands things
like that
uh but so i mean really early on in life
for me uh
i i struggled very much i was a really
uh self-conscious
insecure kid and and uh was
i mean i don't think i had any solid
identity i was the chameleon right where
i was popular because i could be
whoever i needed to be in any
group any situation and that works great
when you're 16
17. you know what i mean uh you can get
whatever girlfriend you want right
because you're always the right guy
uh and you know you have these friends
and and
but when you get a little older you
recognize well this isn't going to get
me very far you know i'm unhappy
none of this stuff is working for me and
and so my personal experience
early on was i had a huge drug problem
right um and so by the time i hit you
know
at 19 20 years old i was that was the
the
i think the first big thing where i was
forced to step back
and say is this actually who i want to
be am i willing to continue down this
road
um you know and i had good friends who
had
you know serious drug addiction problems
i had friends who died i had friends who
were getting arrested these things sorts
of things so it wasn't
it wasn't a purely conceptual exercise
for me it was like very clear
what my potential paths were and so that
was the first thing where i really had
to take a step back and be like i need
to figure myself
out and it wasn't a straightforward
quick thing it took you know a number of
years to get through that but
uh i think since then what i learned was
how critical that that ability to be
self-reliant and independent
and know exactly who i was and what was
meaningful to me because that was what
was driving all of my decisions and
without that again
like i said earlier you're just kind of
flailing around
being discontent for the rest of your
life let's say that someone does
go through their core values and work
out why they're here or they they have a
good concrete idea of that
like what's next like just because
you've got your values written down on a
piece of paper somewhere that doesn't
really mean anything
yeah what's next is the continual
self-monitoring
right and so being being aware of what
you're doing and being
willing and able to ask yourself with
all these decisions you're making
does this reflect who i am and what's
important to me
because so much of of what we do in a
given day is
is habitual right we we continue to do
these behaviors because we've always
done them it's
they're so well ingrained and so much of
the time those things are discordant
with what we actually want to achieve or
who we want to be
uh and so if we don't address that we
kind of just remain on that same course
just through
inertia um and so when we get to these
various
uh you know inflection points or or
forks in the road where we have to
actually make a conscious decision
we have to fall back on these things
fall back on the identity and our values
to make those decisions to ensure that
they are in harmony
with what is actually meaningful to us
because so much of a
so many of us are just driven by uh
convention or tradition or what we are
expected to do or what we're told that
is you know important to us i mean
look at how many people take personality
tests
or or these things that are supposed to
tell us who we are and what we want
and then you know i i'm very very
dubious about the accuracy and the value
of those things
in in so much so because
once you have decided okay well this is
this is my personality i took a test in
cosmo or whatever
uh and so now i have to you know match
all of my decisions and behaviors to
this
well that's the same thing as not
knowing who you are because that's very
likely not who you are
it's just that now you feel like you
have this structure
but it's still leading you down a path
that is not going to deliver
you repeatedly as it should to a sense
of fulfillment and satisfaction
it's an interesting one i had dr
benjamin hardy on the show
uh discussing his book personality isn't
permanent about a year ago and
he was incredibly critical of pretty
much every different personality test
except for the big five
and his reason for not being critical of
the big five was because
you're not put into a type with the big
five they don't say that you're a green
or an mbti
or a a classic classic sparkly dragon or
a new age sparkly dragon or whatever it
is
like it doesn't give you a category that
he feels constrains people
um but yeah man looking at the way that
character relates to capability capacity
and commitment
it seems to me that character needs to
be there to form the foundation
that everything else can be built upon
very very shaky
um underpinnings if you don't actually
understand why you're here and what
you're doing
as mutual friend ben bergeron talks
about he says you can spend a lifetime
climbing a ladder only to realize it's
put up against the wrong wall
and um greg mcewen told me this story
about when
some executive high high flying
executive at some massive media company
he'd been working at for years and years
and he'd sacrificed family time he'd
been doing 18 hour days
five days a week for 20 years and he
finally gets to the top
and he speaks to greg and he says man my
son won't talk to me my 19 year old son
won't talk to me
like i don't have a relationship with my
son because i've never spent any time
with him
my family's in tatters and all that i
want now is to have a family life i've
got
all the way to the peak of this world
that i thought i wanted and look at
what's happened
like i don't i don't want this so you
can very very quickly put yourself in
the wrong direction
if you haven't got this sorted um so
we've got we've got character
in the book there are some core values
exercises that people
can go through and will help to give
them some clarity on that moving on to
capability it's what are you able to do
right that's your capacity
is your ability to deal with things your
capability is what you're able to do
yeah and this is such a a large
umbrella right this is really
all-encompassing again
not just skill and physical ability like
you know strength endurance whatever but
but the knowledge and this is
so much predicated on experience novel
experience varied experience
uh because so many of us are are really
stuck in this very
narrow bandwidth of life experience
where we we have our profession we have
our specialty we have our
narrow set of interests uh we all
watch pretty much the same handful of tv
shows we all look at the same instagram
accounts
uh i mean you look at again going back
to my daughter's generation they all
talk exactly the same where
when i was growing up it was regional
right so where i was from
people spoke one way and then you know
the other side of the state they spoke a
little bit differently and now it's like
every everyone is so tied together
across the world that it's just
so homogeneous and so
we have to break out of that in in go
into
peripheral realms not just for the sake
of learning what's out there but
understanding that the things that you
learn outside of your specialty and your
area of of comfort and expertise will
contribute to
your expertise will contribute to your
specialty
and you don't know how it will because
you haven't ever experienced it
it's unpredictable but also
a huge part of that too is
we we very much overestimate our
abilities when we never get outside the
area in which we're already comfortable
and we develop this this false sense of
confidence
um that that can harm us any time we're
forced to step out of there whereas if
we're constantly
seeking out novel experiences and in
uh you know developing the abilities to
successfully deal with them
now we're building legitimate confidence
we're
creating not just the ability to handle
things that are unpredictable and
different
but we're developing the confidence that
we can right and the more of those
experiences we have where we
successfully deal with things that we
haven't dealt with before
the more we recognize you know our
ability to
to take care of ourselves to uh to
handle the unpredictable to handle
adversity
and so we start chipping away at that
very natural sense of
intimidation and fear and anxiety that
people experience
when you know they have to encounter
things that they are not already
comfortable with and that just
think about how much of life opens up to
you
when you have that attitude and that
mindset and that confidence um
what's that movie yes man with jim
carrey where he just has to say yes to
everything
you don't want to go too crazy right
like you have to be work within reason
there but
that's the idea is is rather than
finding reasons to avoid things because
they're scary or intimidating or
you you've never done them before
you know get out there and dip your toe
in the water at least and
and see what's going on because chances
are you're going to discover things that
are
wildly enjoyable but also beneficial to
what your primary focus is the
interesting thing
about capability is that someone's
confidence is actually a limiting factor
on it
when you think about i am able to do
this physically
or mentally if you put me in the
situation i'm able to do it but if your
belief is
down regulated from that then that's
what you're working off you're actually
working off
80 or 70 or 50 or 10 percent
you know of whatever your available
amount is so let's say that there's
someone who's listening who
is a little bit low on confidence or
doesn't have that self belief
what's something that they can go out
and do
this week or how would you prescribe
them some
strategies for starting to build that
confidence up
well here's the key thing and i talked
about this a lot actually in the
capacity
section of the book but this is like
any other physical training where your
challenges and the exercises you're
doing
um to this end have to be appropriately
designed and dosed so for example like
if you want to
you say i want to go uh learn how to
rock climb
i've never done it before i've never set
protection i've never been on a rope
don't go try to climb el capitan next
week right
you're gonna die you're gonna have a bad
time uh instead you know go do something
small go do some bouldering go do some
top roping with someone who's
experienced
and so these things have to be very
individual they need to be
uh initially of course they should
interest us to some degree
ideally but they should be related
somehow to our
lifestyle our needs you know in terms of
our profession
and our locality because those are the
the abilities we want to develop first
those are our priorities
what's critical for us day to day um
but then you have to determine okay
what's my starting
point because my starting point is very
different from your starting point in
any given endeavor
because our experiences and our
knowledge is different right so for
someone who's an experienced rock
climber maybe they their
next challenge is to you know free climb
the nose of el cap
uh whereas you know i haven't climbed in
23 years i'm not getting near that no i
won't even walk to the base of that
thing right now
uh so it this can be literally anything
and
and for some people it's going to be as
as seemingly simple and mild as
um getting past the anxiety and
going to the grocery store by themselves
i mean that can literally be a huge
challenge for some of us it was for me
as a an older teenager i would run out
of food every once in a while because i
couldn't get myself to go to the store
that's how
out of my mind i was with with
self-consciousness and anxiety about it
um and so it's it's about
sitting down and figuring out where do i
want to go
now how do i break those things down
into smaller and smaller
and more manageable pieces where do i
start what's step one out of
a thousand or whatever it is um and so
i don't have specific prescriptions for
that it's more of a of guidance on
how do you determine what's important to
you what you need to work on
and now let's figure out what's the
first step
right and so i guess what i would say is
think you can figure out today
what is what is something that i i know
that i'm
lacking in capability right now what's
something that's holding me back
uh from what i want to do or who i want
to be i guess is a better way to think
of it
and now what's step one in that
potentially very protracted process
to move me in that direction and so you
create the map and then you create those
little
waypoints along the way to keep you
moving in that direction
you know no matter how uh you know
tortuous it may be
it's very very unlikely to be a you know
a linear uh
course but that's what keeps you on
course uh and and gives you
those little waypoints those little
landmarks along the way is what
stokes your enthusiasm right versus like
oh my god i'm never going to get this
it's such a huge goal
but each one of those little steps is an
accomplishment and that's what kind of
keeps propelling you forward with
greater and greater momentum
what are some capabilities that everyone
should have
uh these things are
in and some of this sounds silly i know
but i think it's really important but
like
the ability to drive a manual
transmission
right that like this is one of those
things i grew up
driving stick shifts and and i finally
got rid of them as i got older because i
got lazy
and i got tired of driving through la
traffic
you know stop and go stop and go trying
to eat a taco change my shirt all at the
same time but
uh you think you think oh well that's
dumb we don't need that
okay what if you are somewhere your
child is seriously injured
you have to get them to a hospital and
the only vehicle available
is a manual transmission and you can't
drive it
are you just going to give up on your
kid so it's like little things like that
you know you people say oh that's so
dramatic
yeah it's it's melodramatic until you're
in that situation and then you go
that greg he was right uh and now your
kid hates you
so uh things like that things like um uh
you know literacy uh being capable of
of reading and comprehending things well
and being able to absorb
information so many of us the longest
thing we read now is a twitter
or a tweet or an instagram caption and
you know i look at um
you know adults my age i just turned 41
and i read emails from people and i'm
like
how have you survived this long with you
know
so much difficulty with the language
like you're missing out on so much
uh without developing that you know
reading more books
writing even if it's just in a personal
journal developing that ability to
articulate and communicate
um so there's a long list in the book of
kind of universal capabilities but
they're they're
primarily about giving us the foundation
to be successful versus specific
long-term
uh capabilities you know being able to
climb el capitan
or whatever uh it's more like what it
what are the foundational things that
allow us to move toward those things
long term
you've got a quote in that section which
i loved which says all
toughness is ultimately mental in nature
regardless of how much the physical body
is involved
a hammer can't pound any nails if we
never pick it up off the workbench or
can't find the nail
such a good quote yep finding that nail
sometimes is the hardest part
yeah talking about capacity i think this
is what
people believe you're referring to
mostly
when they talk about toughness right
like resilience to adversity what you're
able to withstand
right yeah and that these are the these
are the really compelling stories that
we hear
right people who survive you know like i
talk about stephen callahan in the book
survived alone in a life raft on the
atlantic ocean for 76 days
um i mean that imagine
simply being alone being unable to
communicate with anybody for 76 days
even in the comfort of your own living
room
most of us would go crazy like that that
alone is difficult but now you've got
sharks bumping up under your raft your
raft is leaking you're getting blown
around by storms getting soaked you've
got sores all over your body from the
salt water
that's the kind of story where we really
are so enamored with that sort of thing
and so i think that's where we see
toughness really standing out but people
forget that
you know toughness is is demonstrated on
on an
infinite gradient of intensities and
durations and so
we take that example on one end or you
know victor frankel
you know surviving his incarceration in
a concentration camp during world war ii
and finding a way you know uh
psychologically and spiritually to
kind of find that sense of inner peace
and freedom
and we look at that and then we kind of
scoff at the uh
you know you can't get over yourself and
go to the grocery store sort of thing
but it's like
those little things or seemingly little
things are critical to
building the capacity that gets us
through the big things
and so we can't discount those things we
can't trivialize them we have to
put our effort into those things because
that is the practice that's the
foundation
that moves us toward the capacity to
withstand the big
glamorous things falling off the side of
a mountain or whatever it is and
you know walking home with one leg uh
you know
whatever it takes but if if you if
you're unwilling to do the
the work and the day-to-day stuff it's
very unlikely you're going to get to
that point where
stories will be written about you what
was your favorite
story that you researched when looking
at the capacity
chapter i think stephen callahan's
really stood out the the life raft
excuse me he wrote a book
yeah he wrote a book called adrift and
uh this was in
the mid 80s i believe but he was
sailing solo um
uh i forget where he started canary
islands maybe
and almost immediately into this trip uh
a whale
rammed his boat and that thing sank so
quickly he couldn't even get all of his
survival supplies out thankfully he got
the
the life raft that had some gear with it
and so reading his account of that um
it's just mind-blowing because the the
the degree of ingenuity and
resourcefulness that he
displayed is just on such a higher level
than most of us can even imagine like
so much the the fake the favorite for me
is that he had this
this leak in his raft and he was trying
everything in all these different ropes
and knots and trying to prevent it and
it just would never stop leaking
and so he finally ended up using a fork
to fix it
and so you look at the kind of creative
thinking that involves
um and if you see it now you're like oh
no big deal he used the fork as like a
toggle to crank on the thing it's so
obvious
no it's not a fork is something that we
associate with creating leaks not fixing
them
so most of us who are very you know
judicial thinkers
would not even entertain that as a
possibility let alone take the time to
think
here's what i have one of these things
is a old boy scout fork
how can i use this to repair this leak
and then actually make it happen and
save that raft for another 60 days or
whatever it is which those things are
meant to last like a week maybe at best
i think
um and so there were just many stories
like that and in him
having this internal dialogue and he
kind of described
you know having two people in his head
one was a very emotional
um person one was the the more rational
kind of the the captain i think he
referred to it as like nope
this is what has to happen you have to
do this this and this and you know the
other guys and they're like
nah i kind of just want to lie down and
just sleep this away and
forget it i don't want to do it and so
it was
it's just it's this like perfect story
to me of survival
but the the internal
dilemmas and difficulties uh mixed with
the
uh the the necessity or necessity of
being so resourceful and creative and
bringing that all together into this
unbelievable harmony
and then it's so incredible he gets seen
by a fishing boat finally
after 76 days and he's so
dialed in and like accepting of his
situation that when the guys come to
save him he goes
no no you guys go ahead and finish
fishing and then pick me up when you're
done
so he literally sat there and waited for
these guys to finish their day of
fishing
just waited in this raft he's like hey
76 days what's another six to eight
hours
that's unreal you know most of us if we
were in there for six
hours would be like crawling out of
there swimming to the boat get me out of
here and he's
ah you guys i'm just going to enjoy the
view for a little while
so that i mean that book if you haven't
read it that book is very much worth the
time
that's a sick story have you read the
forgotten highlander by alistair ercart
no i've never even heard of it it's such
a hidden gem
so i got told about this about two years
ago from a buddy
think of man's search for meaning
subtract
all of the psychological insights
add in about 10x the amount of
extremeness
and you've got this book it is unreal
so this guy was a in the highlanders
so one of the scottish regiment over in
japan um
and then when world war ii began he was
captured as a part of that when the when
japan left or joined the war and
he gets put on these death ships which
are essentially tin boxes
with 150 people in for a month at sea
with no water and no food he doesn't die
he builds the bridge over the river kwai
uh and is
constantly dealing with dysentery and
like a million tropical diseases at once
doesn't die gets locked in a cage in the
middle of the midday sun for like three
days straight because
he'd done something to piss off one of
the japanese people still doesn't die
then gets shipped over to toward the
mainland
and gets knocked off his feet by the
aftershock from the nagasaki bomb drop
still doesn't die and then stays silent
for
50 years because the army told him to to
keep diplomatic relations
proper and then he writes this book as a
memoir and a call to account
for the japanese government to be um
brought up in front of the world for the
crimes that they'd done against humanity
while he was there and it's so bad but
dude
like if if you want the contrast effect
that you get where you realize
all of the problems that i have are
absolutely tiny and then also to
see the capacity of what people are able
to go through
um it's phenomenal man like seeing
people that can go through forgotten
highlanders
forgotten highlander yes it's a really
easy book it's like 250 pages
super easy read it's uncomfortable read
but it's great
you talked about there about remaining
composed and rational in stressful
situations
how can people build that in themselves
just like i talked about previously this
is something you practice every single
day in even the most
minor situations and so we look at uh
you know so many of us just flipping out
because we have to wait an extra
minute for a traffic light signal or you
know our instagram won't load fast
enough
for us to look at someone else's lunch
or like whatever stupid things we get so
frustrated and irritated and wound up
about
that's where you start is you recognize
that reaction
and you step back and you say is this
really who i want to be do i want to be
the guy who's screaming at my phone
because the wi-fi signal is 2
worse than it should be and then
you you employ the various strategies
that i talk about in the book that are
well known you know uh breathing
techniques
different ways to change your focus
different ways to kind of create that
sense of composure
and then you you build from there and so
then you go into
you know like we talked about the the
various challenges you're going to
create and
employ for yourself and you start
implementing those uh those composure
tools in greater and greater uh
challenges you know intensity and
duration and and variation of course
until you develop that ability and along
with that comes that
confidence from the development of
capability and that that accumulation of
experience
and so all those things uh coalesce to
create that ability to remain composed
in situations where most of us will be
running around like our hair is on fire
uh you know looking for
mom to come figure it out for us what is
the situation that
you still struggle to maintain composure
in
is it getting a red light when you
shouldn't have done with one of your
athletes at a big competition
is it stuff to do with business where
have you still got work to do in this
area
it's it's definitely primarily work
related
um and i think that it it's
almost entirely concentrated on
my anytime i have to rely on someone
else
to do something for my business i can't
take it
because it's never on time it's never
done the right way
there's always some kind of problem and
i'm always asking myself
why am i wasting time and money dealing
with other people i could have done this
myself
and so any anything that like disrupts
my
you know smooth fluid flow of work
still gets me and so i am increasingly
conscious of that and really uh
working to to be able to like take a
breath
and and realize like hey uh you know
we're not storming the beach here at
normandy
it's just a website or you know whatever
the case is and and
like you said like that comparison of
suffering sort of thing
yeah i'm not locked in in a tin box on
the ocean for 150 days
i i'm just a day late getting this
website fix done like it's not
it's not that big of a deal and so being
able to step back and have
that big picture perspective uh is a key
part of it but yeah that's that's what
gets me every time
i agree man so i've over the last year
my main business which is running club
nights has been dialed down
and to operate this podcast which has
been my main project
there's only me and one guy and both of
us know what we need to do
he does his bit and i do my bit and it's
only upon
no longer because i run club nights
which means that i'm dealing with
a thousand drunk students and i i need
to mediate the relationship between the
club manager
and the door staff and the glass
collectors and the bar staff and the bar
manager and this council on the street
and the police on the street
and it's it's a there's a million
different actors all of whom have their
own stake
there's different stakeholders within
the event and making sure that this
thing happens and sometimes they
conflict and sometimes they don't
and then there's a designer and then
there's the guys that run the ticketing
website and then there's all of the reps
and the staff and blah blah blah
and um when you strip all of that back
you realize
how much stress comes from other people
because i think the reason it it
triggers
you and me specifically is that you know
you did
all the things that you needed to do
it's like i did my job i did
my bit and this is being [ __ ] up
because of something that
you did and um that's something i often
think
when we see influences online or very
sort of small
um individual based businesses now so
the
the youtuber that's absolutely smashing
it and he has a team of maybe
like three or four people but he's able
to turn over great money and has
fantastic
um impact but
that person isn't dealing with a million
different stakeholders
they're not dealing with california
state coming and asking you for many
many thousands of pounds per month
that needs to be increased because of
the rent on your gym and other stuff
like that
um and there's two ways that i think
about it one
is aim to create a business in an
industry
that is as insulated as possible like a
hermetically sealed business
in which you have as few external
stakeholders as possible
and then the other side of it is when
you see these people and they're
fantastic and they're doing really
really well
but remember that this massive success
of their business
does not come with the same level of
discomfort as the guy that owns the
delicatessen or the butcher's shop
around the corner
because that person has to deal with
more stakeholders and that is where
as a business owner someone that wants
to make things happen and do them
correctly
that's where so much of the discomfort
lies
yeah well and that's that was one of the
big decisions i made with
with catalyst athletics my own company
is
a number of years back there was a very
clear
fork in the road where i could have gone
full blown
corporate brought on a lot more
employees got the big media team
all these things and it would have
expanded the business and potentially
made it more profitable but
the dilemma was i don't want that i
don't want to be
a manager i want to be a content
producer i want to be a coach first and
foremost
i don't need the added stress of more
overhead and you know a bigger ship
takes longer to steer and you know all
these things
um i got the little row boat man i can
turn on a dime whenever i want
so i i sacrificed some of that potential
top end in terms of profitability in in
spread but i have more than enough of
both of those things
and i retain that complete ownership
that complete control and that complete
enjoyment of what i'm doing and i don't
have to depend on other people
and take on that added stress that i
don't need if i'm going to be stressed
it's because
i'm struggling to you know produce
something that meets my standards
not because i'm waiting on someone else
and i know they're not going to meet my
standards or you know whatever the case
is
and so that that's been like the best
decision i ever made when it comes to
business
i'm glad to hear that i've got a lot of
friends i think who
have big desires for where they want
their companies or corporations to end
up
and i always ask especially when they're
talking about growth and levels of
revenue and stuff like that especially
if it's a big number
if they're talking about yeah ma'am
we're going to try and sort of hit 10
mil top line
next year i'm like in the nicest way
possible man
like how much is enough like how
how much money do you need and i'm all
for growth and i love these
inspirational stories about people that
are able to make
unbelievable apps or products or
services that are
worth millions and millions of pounds
that's fantastic but
at what point is the diseconomy of scale
being paid by you in terms of stress
um yeah and i think that's a question
that it's quite uncool to ask
because in a meritocracy that values
where people get to and you've got
quantifiable metrics of the fortunes
100 most rich people in the world and
how many followers have you got on
instagram
it's not very cool to say that you're
satisfied
um yeah but that doesn't mean that
you're settling
it just means that you know what is not
at all what is
enough
yeah well and that comes right back to
the character and values thing
in when we do our self-evaluation
uh i make the point in the book that
self-evaluation should be concerned
with only two things and that is your
own values
and the the goals that you have set for
yourself
based on those values there should not
be any metrics of self-evaluation
that involve comparison to other people
or other standards because
that's how you pull yourself away from
what's actually meaningful to yourself
so that is the perfect example like well
i've got to clear 10 million a year or
i'm not successful
but what is that actually going to get
to you like speaking of ben bergeron you
know he does the five wise it's like oh
i wanna
i wanna clear 10 million a year why uh
because the and like once you start
actually looking into it you're like
well i don't know why it's kind of a
stupid metric like it's just this thing
that sounds like a good idea because
that's what everyone else is doing
you know i want 500 million followers on
instagram like
why like is that gonna actually make you
content
uh you know i i want that little blue
check on instagram but only because
they've been dogging me for so long and
it drives me nuts
uh but it's not actually gonna make me
happy you know what i mean
like i think somehow i offended somebody
at instagram years ago and now they're
just
they're just doing it to mess with me
despite you that's funny
yeah i am i genuinely believe that you
can
inculcate this you can habituate
reminding yourself
that you're being pulled away from your
core values and until you've done them
you'll never know when it's happening
but in the same way as when you realize
that you've become lost in thought if
you've spent
a bit of time meditating and you realize
hang on
i was dreaming but awake there i was
lost in thought
without knowing that i was lost in
thought that is what it is to be
dreaming while you're still awake
and the same thing can occur when yeah
you get this compulsion
i often get it when looking on instagram
there's a lot of people from the uk that
are out in dubai at the moment because
they fled before the lockdown kicked in
and they're having this great time out
in dubai so i get
jealous about my buddies that i see out
there that are doing this thing
but then i just ask them ask myself hang
on
what why would you want to be there like
what is it
that you're missing and as you start to
dig into it you realize well hang on all
of the things that i value
for my short and medium term goals are
here right here right now and that's why
you made the decision to be in the uk
so it doesn't matter but because we have
this
system one thinking this impulsive just
reactionary
way that it's i want that why why do you
want that well he's got it
that is a [ __ ] stupid reason to want
anything because he's got it or she's
doing it
like yeah and the more that we can
assess our assumptions
the more that we can act intentionally
and until you've got your values in you
don't know when you're being drawn away
but you can habituate it you notice what
you feel when the texture of your mind
is starting to be drawn away from the
the course and the path that you are on
and when you start to get drawn away you
go
there's that thing again there's that
thing there's that thing that just pulls
me away
and then you can just return back to
what you're doing man it is so
liberating
it's so i need to you know it happens i
do it like one percent of the time that
i should do it but
with that one percent it feels like such
a victory
hey that's that's one percent more than
most of us do it
and so a big part of that is is
recognizing that
that feeling you get when you see those
the pictures of everyone partying in
dubai while you're back at home in the
in the rain
uh you know it's it's an emotional
reaction
right and it's it's a it's not a primary
emotion it's a secondary emotion and
it's like that jealousy or envy or
resentment or these
these really uh gross
unhelpful feelings that we get and if we
can recognize that
and step back and say well like you said
why am i feeling this way
we recognize well for no good reason at
all so i'm going to go ahead and put
that aside
and remind myself what i'm doing and you
know having that
ability to take a look at your own life
recognize what's important to you truly
but then also have that sense of of
gratitude
in recognizing okay well i'm not in
dubai
getting drunk with my buddies but this
is what i am doing
and man i am extremely grateful for
these opportunities i have and and
whatever the case is and that really
keeps you grounded and focused on what's
important
versus like you said constantly getting
pulled in you know infinity directions
at a thousand miles an hour
of all these things that you're not
doing well
okay we're all not doing a lot of things
we're
we're not doing a lot more than we are
doing but what we are doing
is important to us and that's what we
should be focused on
i love that man i absolutely love that
talking about
commitment this is the delivery
mechanism for everything that we've
spoken about up until now
you can have the best core values in the
world you can have your capability you
can do a handstand and climb el capitan
but if you're not prepared to actually
do the work
nothing matters at all and yeah i think
that
a lot of people who enjoy listening to
podcasts like this one who like reading
who like personal growth and
self-development
the hurdle that many people's get stuck
at
is action is taking action how can
people take more action how can they be
more committed
funny use that word because at the end
of every chapter that book there's an
action section and it is
practical steps and that was that was
critical for me because
nothing drives me crazier than a
self-help book that's just purely
philosophical and so here's how you
how you should see the world and good
luck actually implementing that
and of course everyone throws the book
to the side of the bed and
goes back to normal so first and
foremost again is once you figure out
who you are what's important to you what
you want to achieve
now you have to determine what the
actual practical steps are
and most of that is going to be
conscious development of habits and
routines
that support those things right so
we do not have the brain capacity to
make
that many conscious willful decisions
every day in our lives that's just a
fact
of of the human brain and i you know
depending on on the source you read it's
40 to 60 percent of the things we do in
a day our habit we're not consciously
deciding
like when we get dressed in the morning
we're not thinking like okay put my left
leg through my pants and then i put my
right leg and
you know it's we just do it and so we
need to create
more routines like that that are uh
conducive to where we want to go
so for example uh simple stuff like
putting your phone on do not disturb and
leaving it in another
room while you're supposed to be working
right
we sit there and work for three minutes
and then we check instagram like
something important must have happened
in the last three minutes like it there
it can't just be a bunch of more
nonsense that i saw earlier
and so developing things like that that
set you up for success
in in help you prevent blocking yourself
from these things that you want to
achieve uh you know reading
every night before you go to sleep doing
some kind of morning journal routine
uh meditating or you know breath work
things like that where you you create
these habits and routines
um that then continue to provide you the
structure the foundation
to reach farther with the more ambitious
things that you want to accomplish and
who you want to become that's really the
most critical part of it it's not
necessarily
saying like oh i gotta get uh you know
super committed to
this long term goal of of uh you know
making it to
to the the south pole right it's more
like
well what do i need to do day to day
that's going to
change my life in a way that allows me
to work toward that goal
uh without constant disruption and
that's what most of us are missing we we
kind of
skip over the basic stuff and just look
for these really lofty goals
and then we're constantly disappointed
because we don't meet them
because our day-to-day life makes it
impossible
what would you say to someone who's
really struggling with commitment
at the moment or quote-unquote
motivation
they feel like they're built for more
they feel like they have some potential
inside of them but
when they promise themselves they're
going to get up at
6 00 am the next morning they always hit
snooze when they say that they're going
to stick to the diet they never do when
they're going to go at the gym they
always miss it
how would you advise that person
so two two things number one is
you have to associate the behaviors
you're trying to
implement with your values
right you have to make that connection
because so many of us look at motivation
like it's this
we conflate motivation with enthusiasm
where if we say like well i don't feel
like going to the gym and training
well i'm not motivated well no you're
probably motivated still but you're not
enthusiastic because it's hard
and you're tired and you got things on
your mind but if you can remember what's
the what's the actual motivation
and that might be that you want to get
healthier so you can play with your kids
or your grandkids maybe that you need to
get
in better shape so that you can do that
big climb or whatever the case
is and so always having that you know
the actual driving purpose in mind to
associate with the behavior
but then also you can start with uh what
charles doing in his book the power of
habit called keystone
habits and so these are things that uh
you know relatively small habits that
support the development of other good
habits and more discipline
and so this is you know the the typical
classic one is make your bed in the
morning
which i'll admit i don't do that one for
me
doesn't mean anything but that's been
helpful for a lot of people where it's
like this one little thing
that they can control and they can
easily create a habit out of
and then it it essentially fuels that
sense of ability that confidence well
i do actually have control over myself
and it's as he says kind of the
accumulation of small wins
and that bolsters enthusiasm and that
pushes that drive to continue to do the
bigger and bigger things but again
it's really critical to understand the
why and then
to start you know it with those smaller
things and build from there rather than
trying to skip ahead to step 10
when you haven't even done step one yet
uh because
that time you constantly get on that
uh hamster wheel and you're just never
actually making progress you're just
constantly
you know being disappointed in yourself
and well i don't have the discipline i'm
not good enough i can't do it
versus like hey i made my bed for 10
days in a row now
what's next i'm going to add on the next
layer now i'm going to start waking up
20 minutes earlier every day for the
next two weeks then 45 minutes so now i
have time i'm used to it now i can get
to the gym in the morning
without feeling like a zombie and hating
my life so it's it's just
the incremental progress i think is key
one of the things that i think is so
insidious about waking up at the wrong
time and this was something i battled
with for ages because
working shifts technically which is what
i could promote it does
you know getting in at three in the
morning inevitably my sleeping pattern
was thrown off
and for anybody out there the nurses and
the taxi drivers and the the people that
do night shift in
in petrol stations and stuff like that
um i feel for you
because it is it's savage and you don't
realize
just how important not hitting snooze is
like as soon as i banned myself from
hitting the snooze button
because it's the first thing it is the
actual first thing
before your day's begun you've already
said i'm going to let today beat me
and hitting the snooze button is like
saying i hate
waking up so much that i'm going to do
it multiple times per day
that's what hitting the snooze button is
um and
that making your bed just tiny you're
totally right little wins on a morning
what are some
tiny little things you can do a five
minute walk like
around the block around the the little
green belts next to your house
just those because it makes you feel
like you're in control of the day
and the commitment there i think is
important and then
i mean coming from a weightlifting
background
everything that we've talked about today
is in some form or another progressive
overload
it really is king absolutely it's king
in everything it's king in reading and
meditating
in learning to do a world championship
snatch or clean and jerk
yeah and that is you know that goes back
to the the idea of dosing with the
challenges and things like that and
with the habit building and the just to
reiterate the point about
starting in the morning with those
habits that is key too because
that sets the tone for the rest of the
day right if you
if the first thing you do in the morning
is that new habit you're trying to
develop
you're already off to a good start
whereas if the first thing you do in the
morning is hit snooze and go back to bed
you've already showed yourself that
you're not able to do it
i had a roommate in college who was
terrible at getting up
and he would put his alarm clock outside
of his bedroom
so he could hear it and he would have to
get up
out of his bed to go turn it off because
by then
you're up right you're not as likely to
get back in bed
of course they used to drive me nuts uh
you know because
we both worked on an ambulance at that
time so we would work 24s
and then i would work graveyard
dispatching shifts from 11 to 7 and
so it was a mess with the sleep
situation but
that's what it took for him to figure
out how to get out of bed in the morning
yeah so get creative you know do what it
takes to get that start
i know i am i have two alarm clocks and
one of them's right there
which is far enough away from bed and
right next to the curtains so i can
drag those open so i've got i've got a
similar strategy putting outside of the
room is
is another level of extreme i can't
believe there's these mats
that you can buy these alarm clocks that
are mats and you stand on them
and they have to have your feet stood on
them for a certain amount of time
to force to to turn them off i'm like
i mean that is just the same as putting
your alarm over the far side of the room
but
fair play to them for finding a niche in
the market for people who want to
be upright for 30 seconds before they
can turn their alarm off or whatever it
is
i've never heard of that but that's kind
of smart from a business perspective
there's another one another one that's
like a really simple rubik's cube
and you're supposed to do the rubik's
cube so you have to
be sufficiently cognizant to turn this
alarm off
but you can imagine if you had a
particularly bad day and you wake up and
you're just
defeated by some rubik's cube and your
alarm's just going off it's going to end
up out of the window
oh yeah yeah it's going to get smashed
under my foot for sure
so what about parting thoughts from this
man obviously we've gone through a lot
today
the the four c's if there was a fifth c
would you have put would you have put
another another chapter in was there
anything that you left out
i mean there's always stuff that you
leave out uh
i don't there was not enough that i felt
required
getting it into the book but i i do
think that is
i think the way i approach most of the
stuff i write is that it's it's a it
a jumping off point right and so these
are
this is a foundation it's a place to get
started there's a lot more to do there's
a lot more to think about there's a lot
more to talk about but
this is what's going to kind of get you
going uh but i kind of saw that as
really a result
of the four c's right that's what you
develop and that that includes kind of
that sense of peace
um that sense of security that we feel
that we're all really looking for
and actually being feeling safe and
secure and satisfied with our own lives
uh versus constantly
you know feeling uncertain and uh and
anxious and
worried about what's to come and so i
think that is really the ultimate goal
is
is finding that really sense of of
inner peace with our lives what we do
and who we are
but then none of those are seized so i
have to go with confidence
i love that man i am i wrote in a
newsletter recently about
what confidence actually is and it's the
belief that your abilities will match
the required abilities of you and
you giving a a public talk
you very well may be a little bit
nervous beforehand because you don't
know
if what you are being asked to do is
what you can do but doing your washing
up is
you're not even going to think about
confidence because you've done it a
million times before and it's not going
to
be
i'm really good at that i'm awesome at
doing it as well actually
and yeah i think
a lot of the time what people think they
want when they talk about confidence is
this
extroversion charisma this sort of
outgoing
bravado they're kind of flamboyant and
they've got all of this sort of
fancy moves everything's done with a
twist like even
even washing the plates up is done with
like a 360 spin
um and that's not that's not what they
mean they just
mean i want to feel comfortable that
yeah i can do the things that are
required of me
and it really does seem like the four
c's that you've given before that would
build up
to um to give someone a firm foundation
as you say a starting off point so tough
building true mental physical and
emotional toughness for success
and fulfillment will be linked in the
show notes below and
catalyst athletics dot com if people
want to get
a thousand plus articles and videos and
how to lift everything
spend the rest of your life happily
perusing that website watching your face
over and over and over again yeah well i
don't know if you want to do that for
the rest of your life but
it's available if you do and
at greg everett on instagram or at
catalyst
it's at catalyst athletics and also um
at becoming tough is the account for
that book so that will have excerpts and
audio clips and things like that for
those who are curious
perfect i love it man thank you so much
for coming on i appreciate you having me
[Music]